une heure que je suis dessus c'est pour
ça je suis enceinte en fait c'est pour
ça c'est pour ça que je préfère terminer
parce que je fatigue est-ce pour ça
c'est confidentiel chef c'est pour ça je
travaille là bas aussi c'est pour ça
pour ça que c'est confidentiel c'est
pour ça c'est marrant parce que
effectivement vous dites souvent c'est
pour ça ça peut plus rien dire
1 c'est pour cela c'est pour ça c'est
mon père c'est pour ça c'est mon mari
c'est pour ça savait que les sushis de
ce midi c'est pour ça je suis fatigué et
c'est pour ça c'est pour ça c'est beau
ça je crois que j'ai besoin d'un petit
remontant
moi je file c'est pour ça demande un pic
à fric pour ça il est temps la wii c'est
pour çà trois fois de suite je me suis
entendu
longtemps je peux pas me parler non je
vais faire une bande annonce je te
rappelle alors grégoire c'est quoi ce
film dans lequel c'est la nouvelle
comédie de quentin dupieux sais qui tu
sais pas quel réalisateur j'imagine je
pense sa part le coup c'est un flic qui
interroge un suspect toute une nuit et
ça va mal tourner et un meurtre ouais le
titre de ville au poste aux fausses
la nouvelle comédie 2 quant à lui qu'
avec benoît ludique
benoît van marcke 13 à la liste de
métiers
philippe duquesne et il plaît à d'autres
acteurs amusant amusant du genre bientôt
je me sens
bientôt sur le hero
[Musique]